[Música]
dos hombrecitos de jengibre racionales
están paseando cuando de repente un
zorro los atrapa los ve tan felices que
en vez de comérselos decide que pondrá a
prueba su amistad con un dilema cruel
preguntará a cada uno si salvaría o
sacrificaría al otro pueden hablarlo
pero no saber qué ha elegido el otro
hasta que cada uno por su cuenta haya
tomado una decisión si ambos deciden
salvar al otro solo se comerá un miembro
de cada uno pero si uno decide salvar a
su amigo y el otro sacrificarlo se
comerá al que se haya salvado y el otro
podrá huir intacto en cambio Si ambos
eligen el sacrificio se comerá
miembros de cada uno en la teoría de
juegos a este escenario se le llama El
dilema del prisionero para imaginarnos
cómo actuarán estos hombrecitos de
jengibre racionales podemos hacer un
esquema con los resultados de cada
elección las filas representan las
elecciones de crispy mientras que las
columnas figuran las de chiwi Por otra
parte los números de las casillas
ilustran los resultados de cada decisión
que se cuantifican en función de los
miembros que conservarían la pregunta es
triunfará la amistad en el juego
en primer lugar consideremos las
opciones de Chuy si Cris lo salva Chuy
escapará ileso porque Chris dice
sacrificará pero si su amigo lo
sacrifica Chuy conservará un miembro si
también decide sacrificar a crispy
sea cual sea la decisión de crispy el
mejor resultado para Chuy implica
sacrificar a su amigo y las mismas
opciones van para crispy
Esta es la conclusión estándar del
dilema del prisionero los individuos se
traicionarán mutuamente la estrategia de
sacrificar al compañero es lo que los
teóricos del juego llaman el equilibrio
de Nash es decir los individuos no
obtendrán beneficios si se desvían de
esta estrategia
tomarán la misma decisión y el zorro por
su parte se atiborrará de pan de
jengibre y los dejará con tan solo una
pierna
la historia normalmente terminaría aquí
pero resulta que un mago había
presenciado los hechos y les dice a
crispy y a Chuy que como castigo por su
traición estarían condenados a repetir
El dilema de por vida y que cada día
despertarían otra vez con todos los
miembros Cuál es ahora la cuestión es El
dilema del prisionero iterado que cambia
las reglas del juego porque los
hombrecitos de jengibre recurrirán a las
decisiones futuras para negociarlas del
presente la estrategia sería la
siguiente cada día ambos decidirían
salvar al otro Si alguna vez alguno
eligiese el sacrificio el otro se
vengaría eligiendo sacrificarlo Toda la
eternidad sería esto suficiente para que
estos pastelitos animados al fin se
decidiesen a colaborar para resolverlo
hay que hacer otra apreciación a los
hombrecitos de jengibre probablemente
les más el futuro que el presente
Dicho de otro modo dividirán el valor
que les dan a sus miembros del futuro
por un número que llamaremos Delta
es como la inflación que
erosiona el valor del dinero
si Delta es un medio valorarán los
miembros del día 2 la mitad de lo que
valoran los del día 1 los del día 3 un
cuarto de lo que valoran los del día 1
etcétera si Delta es cero significa que
no valoran nada en absoluto sus miembros
futuros con lo cual reiterarán su
decisión inicial del sacrificio mutuo
infinitamente en cambio Si Delta se
aproxima a uno harán todo lo posible por
evitar el sufrimiento infinito de perder
los tres miembros con lo cual elegirán
salvarse el uno al otro el cambio de
opinión se producirá en un punto
intermedio
podemos hallarlo escribiendo las series
infinitas que representan cada
estrategia configurando las de igual
manera y dividiendo las por Delta el
resultado es un tercio es decir que como
crispy y Chuy se preocupan por el futuro
al menos un tercio de lo que se
preocupan por el presente es mejor que
se salven y cooperen para siempre este
análisis no solo es aplicable a galletas
y hechiceros sino también a situaciones
reales como los intercambios comerciales
y la política internacional
los líderes deben asumir que las
decisiones que tomen hoy condicionarán
las que tomen sus adversarios mañana
el egoísmo puede imponerse en el corto
plazo pero con los incentivos adecuados
la cooperación pacífica no solo es
posible sino también matemáticamente
ideal tal vez la eternidad de los
hombrecitos de jengibre estará hecha
migas pero mientras conserven una pierna
tendrán una amistad bien horneada
con este vídeo Explore El dilema ético
clásico conocido como El dilema del
tranvía y decida si sacrificaría a una
persona para salvar a cinco
[Música]